foreign
what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation I am joined with Andrew
the Gordon I've already watching today
Andrew watching some Real Steel Real
Steel from Sean Levy who is reuniting
the Hugh Jackman for Deadpool and
Wolverine movie I am so excited for this
I don't know anything about it I think
there's like a father-son story if I'm
not mistake that's probably the one
thing I know about it what are they
doing this let's find out something
about robots I yeah
this is a weird intro ladies and
gentlemen leave a like on this video
punch that like button that'd be very
much appreciated also I want to say
thank you to everyone who's been buying
some real rejects apparel that's right
real rejects we have our own merch that
we uh create ourselves
www.rejacknationshop.com look at this
design look at that design look at that
design we also sell some marble tees we
got more in store that is coming up very
soon so stay tuned ladies and gentlemen
thank you again it's one of the best
ways to support the channel and as
always full-length watch long where you
sync up with your own copy of Real Steel
available for super sexy rejects over at
our patreon page we also cover several
shows exclusively over there with
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included Andrew do you have a pun you've
been waiting to take why do you have to
put me on the spot like that you know
I'm not good at coming up with puns but
I will still I am oh well there I guess
that was what do you think I'm Roxy here
I don't have any friends let's just roll
that in yeah
oh
buff alcoholic he is so out of his range
Phil Panther you want Chad money too
Ambush yeah
you see him Ambush this
oh
cool it's one of those like near-distant
future movies
looks really good I love how everything
is moving too when he hits it what are
you doing can we
can we get five dollars
I won five dollars immediately
could be wrong but I believe those
little girls are Sean Levy's children
you need to stop following directors
children's around yes that's what I do I
was told my bot was fighting at 800
pounds here hey hey that is not 800
pounds
away fight the bull Pam I saw you you're
staring up in the ceiling at the Sam
Houston center with the taste of my
right cross
oh so he's a boxer why don't we make
this more interesting my bad against
your bull straight up I'm a 20 grand
when it takes off you got 20 Grand
Challenge wow
really he really made that a lot more
interesting we had any fans of robot
robot boxing here today
[Applause]
right it's like Rock'em sock'em
he really does look amazing those
effects are incredible yeah especially
in brightly lit Sky it's really hard to
pull off they usually have to Shadow it
up so much
I'm so scared that the Bull's gonna
wreck it why is it fighting a bull why
isn't just fighting another robot
oh
that's gotta be like mocap or something
man it looks way too good
damn that's awesome chappie likes the
bull
ouch
I don't like seeing this bull get beat
up
dude pay attention
stop looking at the are you serious what
are you doing he was mesmerized by how
horrendous looking that blonde girl was
still in this just hop hop oh damn he's
gonna owe so much money I have lost
limbs as Wolverine you can do this oh
God ah
it is getting murdered it's like I'm
trying to get up but you keep looking at
blonde women in the stands
[Applause]
ah bro do you have 20 grand now he owes
money to Jack Bill and this other guy
who really has a Southern accent
just listen to us do you recall Carolyn
Fallon it's my ex-girlfriend have you
seen her in like 10 years what does she
want nothing she died ah recall Max
Kenton he's my son he's got to be like
nine or eleven eleven
is he dead too no he's fine
in the world
so is he dead too
Mother Caroline Fallon deceased oh
recognize the actor yeah there's a kid
from The Sixth Sense young Thor first
movie
what Haley Joel ostman was not in the
first Thor movie my husband
noisy boys for sale damn he's still so
buff I know for an alcoholic who's
always on the road gotta get in shape
for that come on Greg got a demand for
the buttons
being in shape do you even remember me
Deborah Caroline's sister yeah please
take a seat
oh he's the most likable deadbeat I've
ever met
you're taking all the time you
need you better get in good with his
family they got some moolah use that
checkman charm I'd like to at this
juncture step out and call my attorney
that's all right oh he saw The Ring yeah
I'm pretty sure you saw The Ring by that
close-up on the ring you know Deborah
really wants to adopt Max I'm up for it
but um 75 grand you're serious
wow he would sell his own kid like that
we're supposed to go to Italy this
summer with my oldest friend and his
wife two months in Tuscany and all over
Roger sephoria sounds nice such a prank
you're gonna tell your wife I'll only
sign over custody to her if I get to
spend the Summer with the kid first
let's tell her how guilty she made me
feel for being such a terrible absentee
dad
this guy is such an your honor
I'm really happy we all took the time to
make the best decision for everyone is
he gonna regret that decision oh I got
the money take him to Talus Jim and I'll
meet you there wow you know when I heard
the title was Real Steel I thought it
was about robots not this guy's heart a
creepy
the robot in a box
thousand dollar robot when you owe me
six grand rent because three no six
chemistry you're really gonna sell your
dad's gym if you don't make rent I can't
make payments and I won't have a choice
your father would climb out of his grave
and kick your ass there are so many
personal things at stake right now
don't don't do that
it's narcissistic charm on you 50 Grand
as promised numbers right and contact
info over hopefully she doesn't see his
back pocket you did the right thing
giving me custody I think Caroline would
have wanted that back in New York on
August 27th that's a deal
he's such a douchebag I really do like
the look of the film though
yeah interesting shot do you know where
they're going it'll like how do they get
stuck here with you relax kid you got a
whole life of fine living ahead yeah uh
did Marvin give you that money I like
how intuitive he is yeah man he's a
precocious child I'm Bailey Mac
meet your new mom and dad give me fifty
thousand dollars to sign you over tour
will you shut up now
you sold me
just to take care of you just give me
half the money and you won't have to oh
I told your aunt I get you to New York
at the end of the summer not your
concerned Frank Deborah
really is his son's father my Father's
son how much of a challenging
they both are to each other washed up
alcoholic arguing with his child this is
way out of Hugh Jackman's range never
seen him play a role like that
damn
damn that's really cool I've watched
that
fun oh great no the beginning of their
bonding
two things yeah
effects are really good though right
left uppercut
maybe we have to speak another language
the little boy figure it out
it's really smart you can make a lot
more money with the kid around how the
hell do you know Japanese video games
makes sense yeah that's how I know
Japanese too yeah she said to English
and I found his command Matrix gravity
one
that is pretty cool coming with you no
you're not I'm either coming with you or
you're fishing for your
sick of negotiator
[Music]
I do like the similarities between them
get in just
actually the groundedness of the world
is very well realized like when you're
not around the robots and then when the
robots come into the screen yeah it
actually feels seamless and believable
absolutely yeah
what I love about Sean Levy is films
have a lot of heart and he's really good
at capturing wonder even if there's like
a hint of cheese in them you know
it's Furniture playing Eminem with uh
yeah you want to fight Midas 50 000
guaranteed winner takes off they can
make enough money to pay back that money
that that for the kid was she taking
under card five make a little cash and
get the hell out of here I love how
smart this kid is and I'm gonna make
some real cash
we'll take Midas you've gotten into so
much trouble already like why don't you
take some good advice at some point
I mean arrogance is part of his
character arrogance and ego
that's so cool
[Music]
here top looks like Iron Giant with a
mohawk
where do they shoot this
I don't know I mean this background it
has to be green screen because yeah it
looks really great yeah I love this set
though for this
this is a really fun movie who's ready
for some destruction
let's get ready
[Music]
is it quicker to be dictating than it is
to be controlling
gravity slam up down
get your 50k
ah they're bonding
[Music]
Shield
little boy say something give him advice
thank you
oh God damn you can feel it
come on man God this is so frustrating
[Applause]
so frustrating
boy
do you have 50 Grand you never should
have taken that fight thanks genius you
even think about the stuff you do before
you do it I like how the sun's Sun's
telling the dad that
this place is what I want
you don't need yours throw away oh
look into your soul sir don't look at me
like that way get in the truck
I want to see this version of Hugh
Jackman interact with Viggo Mortensen
from Green Book just too high energy
East Coast people
look for some parts I'm coming with you
huh that drink has my heart pounding if
I send this truck by myself my head will
explode
I love this kid I just love how high
energy agitated huge accurate's
performances the entire time
it's almost like cartoonishly at like
the entire movie why would he not be
with so many people thousands of dollars
a bit of that Michael Bay like
Transformers and Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles
cinematography to it but looks better
than both of those
at human Fighters human body so couldn't
give the people what they really wanted
true No Holds Barred violence looks like
in Jurassic Park dinosaurs weren't
enough we got to create some monstrosity
crazy dinosaur
s careful
careful you're on a clip
ah
this Jurassic Park was a good reference
to make
little boy
that additional fifty thousand dollars
you better get that kit
that's the only reason to save him no
nothing else matters
did they land on like a bitching robot
I would assume so but not sure what can
you see what that is because I can't
it looks like there's a robot grabbing
him yeah is it bumblebee I I don't know
and it it grabbed him or it was just
buried there don't have to be scared
it's okay I gotcha you're gonna give me
your other hand oh my God he's
protecting him it's like he's actually
being a father one two
that was sweet
try to get it out what is it whoa
generation one we've got a winner
Charlie
I think there's a whole robot in there
this is Arc he's gonna
that's not gonna happen in this
movie
taking them with me saved my life if I
saved your life let's go
you want that piece of jump you get the
card yourself I'm through here just
never listens to him not only did it
physically save them it's gonna save
them financially It's Gonna Save their
relationship as father that's not going
to happen Greg yeah probably not sorry
I'll do one yeah it's different when you
do it it hurts
oh wow did his dad really make him do it
by himself yeah teaching him character I
do like how it maintains this small town
Vibe at the same time like Countryside
and all that you know it's cool it's
pretty neat there's a lot I really like
about this movie it's really fun
it's understandable I don't know how he
had enough energy to even lift his arms
but that was so cool we just waited
there the whole time and did it did it
helps
but one together you're brilliant at
this there's some good stuff here no
there's nothing here there is look
Charlie
like a conglomerate of them all some
type of hybrid he's generation two but
barely we half the night dragging him
out of there he's mine oh he's yours
yeah but the parts we're putting in them
are mine then it's ours
hey guy
how may I be of service
they're in harmony with each other
they're connected got a shadow function
that's
that's rare oh so he can actually box
hell yeah
I really like the music by Danny Elfman
too so far
[Music]
double meaning the first can we get him
a fight he's a sparring bot right Bill
to take a lot of hits but never dishing
out any real punishment you always try
to sell them off for parts can't you get
him a fight listen to the kid
the Elfman score does really help to
provide the fantasy element
get our cardio in you got to lose some
weight
[Music]
this is really cool because it's feeling
like an actual sentient robot versus the
other ones we just felt manually
controlled
[Music]
everything is Created from Adam's
creation
[Music]
he's like the dad you never had
someone
[Music]
your secret safe with me
it is living it was kind of grew up in
this gym my daddy dad your dad and you
always mentioned the day
that's Charlie
we like
the boxer
quit no fear I just know him as a
deadbeat the top Contender number two in
the world and Charlie was dancing with
him he was beautiful
beautiful Michael Tandy rung my bell and
went on to be the undefeated World Champ
for the next three years so he knocked
you out oh yes
did you ever fight for the title yeah
you do we leave in an hour I think it's
fine I'll look it up on Wikipedia I do
feel like the Evangeline character
severely in hurry all she does is talk
about her dad and and
I'm like I don't really know her
severely underused you mean underwritten
everything oh Underwood that's what you
wanted right me gone yeah that's what I
wanted
you can tell in the subtext of her voice
sir and the way she talks about you she
definitely wants you gone yeah I hope in
the next scene she mentions her dad and
or him entirely yeah
good night
I think the the World building around
this is really really really well done
like they're grounded in reality just
like wonderful you know it just feels
like the next stage of the exactly how
they set up the world that it's just in
the near distant future
behind the father-daughter Zeus team
they say your father's the money and you
are the Mind behind Zeus but I assure
you the man behind those belongs to the
gray
is this talk machito's greatest creation
he's adaptive operating system he
recognizes patterns and rewrites his
fight code that's amazing no matter what
happens in that ring the results of any
fight is inevitable
well that makes bedding a lot easier I
would tell Charlie you know who to bet
on
to the design of all the robots is so
good in this movie
that's like Rock'em sock'em like you
said earlier is that what you think
boxing is who's beating up some piece of
Steel did they feed him and I love it
and I'm in it now
not adapting to the boxing world now
well they need to be a blend of the two
there's a lovely place called the zoo
tomorrow afternoon you'll get your fight
it will be the end I told you I hate
burrito laughs
you've been up all night yeah I cleaned
him up broken some fight music
I saw that too he's in such good shape
in this movie I really think Hugh
Jackman had to play his performance a
little bit
more it's slightly above real that way
we could like him otherwise he'd be a
very just unlikable guy
fight my bro
my robe get in there with Metro I want
500 for two rounds it's good this kid is
so good if he's still standing
[Applause]
I'm really fascinated by the world
because whenever they're traveling or
going through the city it just feels
like our world and then when they go to
matches it's it's a completely different
kind of world
[Applause]
like the cast of characters is so
different
[Music]
[Applause]
she was like an apocalypse don't watch
Adam watch your opponent watch him watch
out for that funny looking opinion
[Applause]
ah
all right oh here comes the sledgehammer
[Applause]
Robo apocalypse
combine your brains
oh poor guy
poor guy
I got some green fool oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
I love this thing
[Applause]
yeah
he survived around
[Music]
I need the money I know that's why I did
this dude I love this kid they have good
chemistry too yeah but like a lot of
kids sometimes can be annoying
characters and he's he's not he's very
well written oh he's learning
he's learning out there
I love it the dad's like impressed with
his son awesome
[Applause]
[Music]
now what do you think about your son
this is so fun they've been losing for
an hour
felt like Spider-Man 2 or Peter Parker's
just continuously losing all film no I
know I know
[Music]
does the kid get any of that money I
mean he's the one who dragged him into
the truck and did the fight he doesn't
need the money I understand that but he
wanted the 50 Grand too remember from
his dad can you believe that the kids
robot actually won
I know I love him gotta keep I can make
more than 50 Grand off of him I'm
keeping this kid it's their final match
with Zeus gonna conflict with when he
has to bring him to New York I think you
should still give him away but keep the
robot I don't believe it in this change
of heart stuff you're gonna be a good
dad one day yeah yeah you could still
kill yourself
who was the kid
today's sponsor my child
[Music]
come on dance dance for me robot
go little white boy
it's gonna say they should maybe join So
You Think You Can Dance or America's Got
Talent could make a lot of money doing
that as well
[Music]
and take the circuitry sleeve out of
noisy boy and it works I mean he knows
nothing but it works guys they're
teaching so many things in video games
nowadays I know God damn I need to play
more videos seriously
I need you to teach you in a box you
want to have a robot drink some Dr
Pepper
box in a long time I'm not starting now
you're doing fine Max you don't need me
my God he's gonna find his passion for
boxing again via his kin I think Ali
Sugar Ray prince Joaquin gamut they all
had their nicknames they had their
personas they all have Flair you might
not have much robot but with that dance
you got Flair Floyd Money Mayweather
people want to see that
and we can make money
hahaha
I won't do it unless you help me I can't
dance you're on your own there
oh we know you can dance
oh yeah make the robot drink Seven raw
eggs trained to be Wolverine this is
what we gotta do
that's it
I wonder how long a boxing train for
just curious do you think that guy he
owes the 20 grand to at the beginning
with the bowl is that coming back at all
or Nah Nah
Eminem do a uh this is Eminem and Royce
the five nine
oh damn they're doing the dance
oh damn great swing damn oh like how
that robot's got a cowboy hat oh no more
cowboy hat
damn making some he's like the original
plan the increments yeah
[Applause]
this reminded me of Lionheart now with
Jean-Claude Van Damme
[Music]
Virgin America Spectrum Detroit Friday
night that's a league fight
are you say fellas you ready for the
show somewhere in Italy his Guardians
are freaking out well I don't think they
do you think they know about that I'm
pretty sure they follow it religiously
definitely they seem like the characters
who would I want you to be relaxed okay
Max no freaking out
he's so anxious
it's fun you gotta have fun you
understand me we've come too far to get
out there and freak out and blow this
whole thing we're gonna have fun he's
talking to himself so much
is this Hugh Jackman every day before he
goes on set this is me before I film
with you
just gonna enjoy the reaction Andrew
we're just gonna do this don't worry
guys he's he's actually being serious
you have been invited to lemkova Suite
One More Time sweet Zeus sweet
dough
set up to the champ sweet
I had a feeling that's possibly oh my
God I want Adam to just break free and
do his own thing now oh
prisoner of their bond ship I'm
important fights tonight so I'll get
right to it you can offer oh for the
robot yeah
I'd like to buy your robot
it'd be a useful spotting bot for Zeus
and for that I'm willing to pay 200
000 dollars
15 minutes away from getting in the ring
with Twin Cities my offer stands until
the starting Bell he's not for sale
over the top I love it I think it's
worth 200 Grand 200. man
Charlie we can go round and round this
all night long look at me look at me
the two-headed Tyrant
[Applause]
dude all the sets for all the matches
fantastic
oh my God it's like a Siamese robot I
was thinking that too I'm glad you said
it hailing from Parts Unknown
at home
let's go Adam atom let's go atom
yeah that's gotta be mocap right yeah I
think it's a mocap robot yeah it's just
way too good
that's a real robot on set I'm saying
it's not just like CGI It's gotta be
vocab yeah
I love this I love it and I think it's
well Justified for this story too look
over there see those Geeks with the
joysticks and consoles they're
controlling everything that bot does
this is the league stand on that
I'm a heads up about that
break why didn't we get the 200 Grand
oh he's been so incredibly overrun I
love Hugh Jackman's performance in this
movie
the robot designs are so good in this
film too yeah that's right come on
boom
it's so fascinating they have two guys
controlling it I know it's like Pacific
Rim I never saw it Oh add it to the list
okay
oh my God oh my God oh my ah oh my oh my
God this guy's got two heads
stop being in your own head wait wait
wait
he's got a hitch in his shoulder every
time he throws that right box to hit it
stop talking about it yeah
nice nice
[Music]
[Laughter]
block off oh yeah
Charlie special
whoa
oh she knows his moves
[Music]
[Applause]
I love this I'm loving it this is so fun
[Music]
this is cooler than re-boxing although
I'm sure the many boxing fans out there
are in disagreement with me they haven't
hugged yet they haven't hugged yet it's
not happening not happening
whoa
what's he gonna say
I love how they're just letting him do
it
who won't be named for raw lemkova oh
what is he doing
okay I'm just gonna find my robot and
you think you're my you're my control
why not
the biggest shot
Whoa We Are nearing the finale we need
to get there yeah
suits
I mean would they would they still
saying the rocky Lots
oh he's like let's get out of the
ring now would they still get paid just
to fight though you know does it work
like that with a boxing match they could
probably still walk away with a lot of
money even if they lost you know they
only win if they lose if they only win
money if they win the fight all right 70
30 right yeah 70 for me and 30 for you
that's very funny very very funny so
the progression of their relationship is
very very natural yeah they're taking
their time they're not rushing it even
though it's obviously it would happen of
course but they're not rushing it oh my
god dude hey 20 grand guys back don't
worry about that that was a heck of a
fight it was an amazing fight that was a
great job young man Oh I thought I was
joking when I said I beat you within an
inch of your life he thought that was a
joke how about that just give him the 20
grand use the robot I have your money we
don't have a problem Rick oh I'm sure
you do Charlie but I think we know it's
about much more than just money now
don't we
okay 125 30. you want 30 grand I got the
money in cash right here
all right now the robot's gotta get help
them crap oh no don't not the kid
oh yeah use that boxing
hey Ricky oh that's his money leave him
out of this
oh oh
damn Wolverine
oh this is actual box that's cool
come on Adam come in there and help oh
your friends are real Dirtbag kid
America
damn the first time he called him his
dad let me call him daddy call him or
his father label given the title
oh man
I called that and all his lost moment
people
oh his aunt uh boy I called her look at
us we're a mess
fine she can leave Adam's fighting good
we can make the money back
please
call him Dad yet legally she has custody
so what what can I do I think they would
want to do what he would little boy
really wants you know
I don't want you money Marvin what at
least take the 50 Grand what do you want
me to say I'm sorry you decided to take
the ride Max you thought me you and him
broke off in the chunky we're gonna ride
off into the sunset you don't need to
push him away like this man no you you
forgot who I was you deserve better
um
than me he's doubting himself as a
father especially after he's got beat up
man I tried okay I mean what do you want
from me I want you to fight
that's so sad oh it feels a lot deeper
than I was expecting it to be I think
they wrote the little kid a lot better
than I anticipated it's actually one of
my notes very premature because we're
still actually watching it's one of my
favorite child characters sure sure I've
seen
[Music]
back to who they were at the beginning
of the story self-reflection
you're back I got to talk to you about
you or my dad
father just one once more
really looks like the set that that
particular gym looks like the set of
Ghostbusters where they have the app
perhaps
go this way
it was like he was in your corner from
day one me come on I blew it that's the
whole character okay it is her acting is
fine it's just the character who's just
like you said it's very underwritten
would know where to start
come on come on
oh there's a glow go get him Charlie
I know nothing about her character
because he loves your dad she really
loves her dad and everything about her
dad she loves Charlie she loves Charlie
you have no business being here that's
true uh you've got full custody he's
yours and and I know I've done all kinds
of wrong by this kid but if you'll let
me
make a lot of money with him yeah we
want to fight Zeus and I'll bring him
right back
right yeah
and you slept on a shelf in a truck and
it was awful and dangerous really
dangerous
came to tell you that I heard you
I got it I want to fight for him and I
know you had a bum ride Max and I wasn't
there and I should have been your mom
was she was the coolest
she was I'm sorry about I haven't heard
much better day
what happened with her and I can't get
those years back max but but I'm here
right now and if you're up for it I'm
ready to fight
hug hug hug
he was blocking that whole view we got
the Zeus fight
no we didn't
well you've proven you're a good father
so yes
one night thank you you know we'll
probably get our asses kicked but at
least we'll go down swing and on
National Television for everyone to see
I mean the good thing is it's not
dangerous for him yeah that's true like
true he's not getting him actually hurt
yeah
[Music]
I want to see the aunt and the aunt's
husband watching the match on their TV
yeah they got to be on one being like
come on right hook left hook
[Music]
[Applause]
these characters man 100 cases Adam
doesn't see round two remember section
101 row C and you can bring me my money
right to my seat oh
boy
all right really really
he's one of the bad guys do you have to
have subtle racism to drive home how bad
it is yeah I said subtle racism very sad
yeah
[Music]
oh my God it's Shredder
from the 2014 version best Turtles movie
ever
[Music]
so you're gonna just jump over I hope he
flips
[Music]
oh superhero Landing in about scheduled
for five rounds they showed up they
showed up I guess I was we were wrong
about that being watching I mean he does
have 50 Grand to spare so she's got some
front row seats are you ready for
[Applause]
Espin what a fun fictional Sports
Universe yeah never heard of it whoa
oh the dent Mark too damn
this is like what'd you look what kind
of fight did this kid get me involved in
oh second time
he just keeps getting back up man
I don't think getting his hands up
because then to do anything
back in there oh my God he's like
fighting dragon
whoa if he dies
oh no
for Christ's sakes Adam get up oh
Just Go the Distance dude command him to
do something though feel like you uh
Charlie's nuts thank you
oh finally said something though
clearly never saw it coming advance
yeah you didn't see that man come on
there's like
damn ah five seconds left get out of the
corner
wow
yeah
[Applause]
homeboy let's go home
how does it feel to be on the other side
of that punk
good Corners fear Fury damn
gloves would help it's like NASCAR
Kenton working his butt with a trifecta
[Music]
let's go let's go the distance
oh my God
this is April
wow awesome this is such a great match
yes you call that
yeah
dude look at the Den marks on his face
he's gonna probably take the controls I
would imagine
whoa the spin move
lights are seeing Stars
I think the voice recognition is not
responding what you gotta get it but you
put the you have to box yourself
that's like Donnie Yen in it man you
can't hear me
you gotta do it yourself sounds in once
again what I like about Zeus is the way
he moves is just like like an actual
robot there's not much in the shoulder
so he's like robot and a brawler at the
same time
yeah you've got actually box man
this movie's giving me everything I want
no way
come on you have to fight the last round
you gotta believe in yourself there's
more than 50 Grand on the line right now
are you kidding me with those eyes
[Music]
damn it
it's like this is what I got in shape
for for this movie for this scene I know
you can't hear me but you can see me so
watch me this is so cool are you talking
to a robot I know
watch me throwing his own line back at
him I like that
[Applause]
commands see him in the background
that's so cool
whoa are you singing Charlie can you
Shadow Boxing just outside the room
this is so great he's fighting the last
round of this fight against us back up
against the ropes again
[Applause]
oh he's waiting waiting for an opening I
think personally
oh oh it's like Rocky taking
the hits he's tiring him out I'll Tell
You Folks the champ looks tired yeah oh
my gosh guys they're clever legging it
[Applause]
believe it Adam is taunting Zeus Mr
Turbo he's actually asking for more
oh yes
fuel Gatling guns of Zeus's blows
[Applause]
they're all Fighting For Adam
yeah foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
that was amazing
that's so cool that was so awesome
oh he brought his dad that is beautiful
yeah that is beautiful he's got a big
smile on his face and his dad's love for
boxing yeah
oh it's the he's beautiful isn't he oh I
love that shot you can see both of them
yeah isn't he beautiful
oh no matter what we win let's get an
action box oh
oh yes
my man
you want more to knock his head off
knock his head off
oh my God
he's got to have won right oh
the actual glass
oh
say my dad would be proud say it
if she does I'm just I'm I swear
and still world robot yeah it's Rocky
it doesn't matter though it does not
matter he went the distance there true I
know
the whole crowd is against them now it
took a little longer than we start but
the result is as expected she's the
Russian girl from Rocky IV any comment
on the absolutely humiliating near loss
yeah it looks like he's gonna deck him
okay
they're already
ready I like the name sound of that what
do you say to that sounds pretty good to
me call him dad right here give me what
I want
[Music]
[Applause]
he's calling him dad
[Music]
movie
[Laughter]
really heartwarming story I need you to
know
don't worry I know
your secret's safe with me
[Music]
what's he gonna do yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
they may have lost the match but they
won the people's hearts and respect
that's such a great shot at the end too
crying you're crying
now let's watch Hotel Transylvania for
Via Amazon's recommendation I haven't
seen any of those but that's like the
perfect uh I would skip right to four as
well that's like the perfect movie to go
to I would imagine after this
ah yes no seriously that movie was again
the only thing I knew about that movie
you uh obviously knew was a father-son
story I only knew that there was boxing
and robots
um so it was a lot deeper than I was
expecting it to be which I was
pleasantly surprised about I think that
was the obviously you know no pun
intended but it was the heart of the
film uh obviously the character
transformation of uh Hugh Jackman's
character Charlie uh just what his son
was able to uh
you know help him uh transform from a
heartless bastard into uh you know a
wonderful loving father who made some
good money off of him of course
um but transformed yeah right right
that's the the key word here so you
couldn't get a pun out of mirror there
but yeah I'm just planning away but oh
by the way I gotta interrupt you I keep
forgetting to do this I gotta interrupt
you
if you are listening to our review on uh
you know pot uh like any of our Spotify
or apple or anything like that please
rate this video we just watched Real
Steel literally start talking about
right after I have a tear I just wiped
off my face he did I can see it right
now seriously he did yeah
um but seriously that uh I I have not
seen many Sean Levy films I've only seen
Night at the Museum so have you seen
free guy I have not that's awesome I
have not seen any but I was already
excited for definitely not worth
reacting to yes definitely what everyone
says no it's not the kind of movie
that's words or reaction yeah but
um I was already extremely excited for
Deadpool 3 but this film just got me
even more ramped up and I I gotta say
too
um I'm not the biggest fan of uh child
characters I think they're very
difficult to direct and very hard to
write I was extremely pleasantly
surprised with not only the acting of
this young boy who of course as I
mentioned a few times played the young
Thor in the Kenneth branagh's film the
same year 2011. uh he did a fantastic
job uh but I just I loved his
relationships and interactions uh with
Hugh Jackman it was just to me again the
heart of the film I just thought he was
so well written I loved how intuitive he
was and uh just those were my favorite
scenes in the film I know probably most
uh
the most entertaining scenes of the film
of course are the the robots and all
that but I I loved the scenes with him
and his dad but what'd you think of the
film
Thai
I hated it I know I think that any
criticisms I would have
are not necessary
I think they they came and went and I
don't really feel like they need to be
something to really harp on my only real
thing was about Evangeline Lily like it
was it wasn't fun with her I like her I
like Evangeline Lily
um despite whatever controversy she
might have had I like her performance
here and uh I believed I thought they
had good camera she had good chemistry
with them regardless uh and then my only
real complaint is like she's very she's
very underrated this is one of those
movies that's like it's it's predictable
right from the jump like it's extremely
predictable movie
but at the end of the day you're like
but I wanted to go down that path and I
I want the plot turns to happen that
this movie is very much obviously
setting up you want it to go there and
it's all about the execution so you
still get the catharsis you're still
having fun I pretty much had a smile on
my face from beginning to end with this
film uh the performances themselves Hugh
Jackman I thought had such an energy
here it was so it was so big and so
heightened and it wasn't like too over
the top but it was like just over the
top enough where I found it very
Charming because and I think I do think
it was required due to the fact that his
character is such an unbelievably
cold-hearted in this world of a
robot fighting boxing matches that he
needed to be that so that way he still
be charming and he's the leading
character this is a big Hollywood movie
so he's got to be likable to it because
he's so Charmed it's it's like he's so
cold but so unbelievably Charming at the
same time and the way he is about his
kid that it needed to be a little bit
over the top in order to sell it you
know and so I thought he was great I
agree with every point you made about
the the kid I thought that he was a
wonderful actor I'm sure by this point
in his life he is an adult officially
and I thought he was a really nice
addition and the way their relationship
evolved like yeah you know the plot
beats are gonna go you know that yeah
they're gonna start off distant but by
the end of this movie they're gonna be
like a real father and son and he's
gonna learn about himself and find his
roots again and realize that he's just
out of his walled up his entire time and
he's going to learn to love his dad like
you know you know exactly where it's all
going but the way we got there via this
plot point of them finding
um harmony with each other and and
kinship and bonding via this robot
fighting Journey I bought it I thought
it was believable and the the little
moments that they would have with them
of how they got there were the things
that made it feel rewarding and
had me invested because it's like as
well I thought the plot beats were
predictable of course certain scenes
that they would give us I did it like I
didn't think we'd go to a zoo with an
apocalyptic fighting I didn't really
anticipate that they would find some
special robots together that they would
put together themselves and that would
be the thing you know like I didn't see
that coming you know I mean I did once
you they pulled it out of the rubble but
you know what I mean like yeah before it
had happened I didn't anticipate that uh
yeah I I think that it was just a truly
entertaining film that ultimately just
kept giving me what I wanted with a true
it had such a spirit and a heart to it
and the fighting Andrew what did you
think of the fighting the fighting was
great it was really entertaining but
also like it it felt I know it's robots
and probably mocap like you said I don't
know but it it felt grounded as well
like I mean I really felt like I was
watching boxers really fighting even
though again it was robots but I think
you made a great Point while we were
reacting like they did such a good job
of making it I mean keeping the actual
World grounded not so futuristic that
when we did get the fighting or the
robots actually doing their things the
illusion became so real you know what I
mean you bought it yeah so I thought
that was a really smart choice and I
think again to another point you made
about yeah there's a lot of plot beats
that you know are gonna happen
which a lot of times I prefer not I I
don't care for knowing things that are
gonna depends on the kind of movie
though yeah of course of course but
because the execution here is so good
and the interactions are so good I don't
mind it yeah as much so like who gives a
shame yeah for sure and that's why it
didn't bother me in any way shape or
form I mean I was and also too another
thing I really loved too there were two
other things I really loved I loved that
they were really taking their time in
their relationship like they could have
completely rushed then oh okay uh like
after a couple scenes that they're uh
they're really getting along and sorry I
just realized too because I kept making
compounding jokes about like oh
alcoholic buff guy this is a stretch rip
alcoholic buff guy who's arguing with
this kid is a structure it's not not
just that alcoholic buff guy
on this relationship with his with his
strange child on the road it's like so
Logan
no I was thinking Logan I didn't even
factor in
no I definitely was thinking Logan a
couple times throughout the film for
sure absolutely yeah definitely but uh
yeah I love that they they really you
know they let the film breathe or in
terms of their relationship they let it
breathe they didn't rush that uh the you
know the transformation of their
relationship where they you know kind of
met in the middle and uh bonded I love
that uh so you know I bought it more but
also too it didn't feel like it was a
slow burn like I thought the film was
really paced well at the same time yeah
um so yeah I know I mean a lot of goods
I was a lot deeper than I was expecting
it to be too like again the only thing I
had known about it was it was a boxing
film with robots that's all I remember
from the trailer years ago yeah I didn't
know anything about this a strange Sun
I just I remember I heard something
about a father and son movie and and
robots fighting but I I I couldn't tell
you like exactly what the plot was at
all
um and and I thought that them I thought
the
I do think that at times when they would
go into the the world of the of the
matches that it could feel a little bit
jarring to the juxtaposition of the real
world that it was fleshing out but I
actually wouldn't have it any other way
because because it would feel like so
realistic and then suddenly it was like
oh now we're stepping into like a comic
book you know they would have this
juxtaposition but the right the the the
way the the robots were designed I
thought was really cool just about to
ask you that yeah I feel like they
wanted to set this up for a franchise
but I appreciate the variety you know I
think what I would have liked is uh just
to
I guess semi further enhance the
experience is
in terms of the choreography and the
movement per robot to get a little bit
more like something that made their
style unique but more distinct yeah yeah
that so I think in the final match with
Zeus there's a certain kind of it really
was like Drago and Clubber Lang versus
Rocky Balboa you know totally and and
they take their Inspirations because
there is a bit of cheese to this movie
that I think is intentional it felt
intentional there is a cheesiness that
was kind of permeating through the
screen little by little throughout the
film where you could feel some of it so
much into earlier films there were times
it has a bit of that Lifetime movie hard
to it you know but it felt purposeful
and I enjoyed having that slapped on me
absolutely I did feel with Adam he
definitely had his own distinct and
unique set of moves especially that
spinning move and then the flying punch
I agree with you it would have been nice
to get that on some of the other robots
that he was facing I got him I mean it
was probably a purposeful choice I
couldn't imagine like budget wise and
choreography would have just taken a lot
more work and all that but um would have
been a cool choice but yeah that that
match at the end though was like I I was
not expecting to feel so much suspense
and tension yeah I was in a film like
with robots just going at it in a boxing
match so like I said this movie was just
a lot deeper than I was expecting it to
be and at the end like the heart of uh
the heart of it just a son and father
like coming together yeah it was a
little predictable with the Beats but
again you don't care because it's
executed so well and I thought Sean Levy
just again I'm I'm really excited to see
not only Deadpool 3 obviously but just
more of his uh his other films uh it's
really really a good director yeah it's
all warmth to this movie man and the the
music I thought might have stood out a
bit more just because I saw Danny
elfman's name slapped onto it
I'm only disappointed by the fact that I
see Danny elfman's name so I thought
it'd be a little bit more distinct I'll
say this and first of all I'm a die hard
Danny Elfman fan I listen to him every
day at the gym Pandora's radio Danny
Elfman radio so I can say I am uh Edward
Scissorhands is actually my favorite
film score of all time Danny Elfman from
first film of course was PeeWee Herman's
uh uh
Herman's uh big adventure 1985 from 1985
to about 2003 up until Big Fish he was
the top three top four greatest composer
from that point on he still had a couple
good scores here and there Sweeney Todd
was amazing I haven't seen the film but
the score he's had a couple good scores
but from that point on he just has not
been able to be old Danny Elfman so I am
total agreement there were a couple
beats in the film where dramatically I
was really it was touching but overall
he's not been able to be and again when
I say ultimate of men we're talking like
one of the greatest composers of all
time so it's working yeah yeah no no for
sure but like when I've heard Terminator
Salvation or when I've heard Justice
League I'm like
it's a mild criticism but I totally feel
for you I feel you because like when we
hear the old Daniel we're like damn this
guy is so freaking good yeah but totally
yeah
um and then I guess uh
again it's it's only semi-jarm when I
was saying they step into the world of
of the of the of the like the boxing
matches it's because the characters
or so much out of like a comic book or a
cartoon you know what I mean like you
got the zoo people which feel like a
barbaric apocalyptic characters you got
the extremely Southern Cowboy guy you
know you got this guy who is like out of
the Japanese gangster World who's
deciding that me and I did and I don't
know what accent that woman had but yeah
they felt like but I preferred a movie
with a colorful personality to its
characters then Bland boring characters
and which kind of does trying a little
bit more of a spotlight on you know like
oh that's really kind of like dropped
the ball a little bit for the Evangeline
Lily character I felt like they just
kind of wrote her like a little bit too
dry but overall everything I wanted to
happen happened everything I predicted
would happen pretty much happen right
down to it's all those lost moments you
know you know what's going to happen
because you temporarily give the kid
back whatever but I thought the ground
they fought they found too was smart on
that like he's not gonna just adopt his
kid uh he hasn't earned at the end of
the day he truly hasn't earned that to
to have full custody of the child but to
be able to be in his life and have a
relationship with him that's what really
matters and that's what counts so I
thought
I thought it might have gone down that's
the one part of the movie that I
actually thought they would have done
that didn't happen where he would end up
adopting his game yeah we're not
adopting him yeah before the last match
like okay he's Gonna Be With You full
time he's yours and which wouldn't have
been very realistic it's like wait what
has he done exactly yeah it's only been
a few months yeah they had a little bit
of bonding and I mean but I mean he got
beaten up they've made some money and he
still abandoned him all these years yeah
exactly so I mean slowly but surely I'm
sure I'm sure the aunt and uh the aunt's
husband are gonna let him continue to
spend time with him and all that but he
I'm glad they didn't go that route
because that would have taken away from
the crowdedness that we've gotten and
how realistic so far the film has been
so I'm I'm glad they didn't go through
that Trope because that would have been
completely generic if they would have
done that so and this movie's funny too
yeah I love the look of it a lot some
really striking cinematography I loved
all the sets too when I
they had so many different creative uh
you know you could feel that they I
imagine this movie initially
underperformed or otherwise would have a
sequel by now I'm not I'm not gonna lie
to you when I saw the trailer for this
movie it's not like I went I this looks
terrible I just I don't have any I love
you Jackman I'm like I'm not interested
well I was completely I'm pretty sure it
got lost in the void of like robot
movies there's like Transformers I think
that's probably what it was I was
probably like I'm tired with the robot
movies and I should have given this one
a chance but on the flip side I'm glad I
got to react to it for you guys yeah man
and um I I think I think I've seen every
Sean lady movie now at this point let me
confirm that I I don't know if I've seen
I I think I've seen the First Night at
the Museum I'm not sure
let's see what I haven't seen of his
before we shout someone out
all right hold on a second
hold on a second
no no there's all these produced 43.
there's a lot of show stuff though too
he's director of 43 movies
that would be insane
can you imagine director 43 moving
that's a lot
like yes it mainly shows I've even seen
the internship
haven't seen any of these movies oh he
directed Pink Panther I've seen Pink
Panther unfortunately I haven't seen
sorry I've seen Cheaper by the Dozen as
well I haven't seen that he's a big fat
liar I haven't seen that didn't I think
I watched maybe five minutes of that
movie oh there's actually a lot of
movies so it seems like he's upped his
game as a director yeah yeah I want to
start a game but like not the music so
he did do all the night at the music I
haven't seen that I haven't seen two and
three I've I've only seen the first one
um should I add it to the list Craig
Maybe
maybe think about this guys alrighty
guys what did you think about this film
did you love it do you find it
underrated
do you know where John put the list of
the shout outs for people because I'm
looking for it right tell us in the
comment section where did where did John
put the shout out Greg is trying to
fight and we found it thank you for
letting us know people oh my God yes and
um hey before we go why don't we do a
patron of the day shout out all right
Andrew yes here's what we're gonna do
today buddy what are we gonna do today
we are going to have in the honor of
robots
we are going to have chat gbt oh boy
write a shout out all right so okay
um between these three names pick one
okay uh let's go with Kevin smart Kevin
smart all right now let's
um let's uh let's let's play a little
bit of Mad Libs here first of all give
me and uh give me an item
an item any item
doesn't matter first thing you can think
of Andrew treasure treasure very very
broad out of their treasure treasure
give me an adjective
spot so the adjectives like do you know
what an adjective is I know it's
no yes maybe adjective is like uh you
know uh how do you explain what an
adjective when you're when you're
describing like if something's big or
small or I'll just go with small you
know like uh
um how can you explain
explain to me what an adjective is it's
activity
this is fun when an adjective is
all right
so let's see if as far as HSN modifies
or describes or not a pronoun get okay
oh my God this is way too like a red
apple that's great like the red is the
part of it like apple is the object
that's the noun and red would be the
adjective to describe it
you get it
so something that describes something in
a way yeah uh like a blue cup
there you go yeah you're getting it so
um what was the first item treasure
treasure okay a gold okay let's go with
gold treasure adjective let's go with
um uh
tiny and then
um
give me
um an article of clothing
an article of clothing yeah
uh shorts shorts perfect thank you my
favorite gold treasure tiny shorts
superhero
Iron Man
favorite celebrity any celebrity Arnold
Arnold Schwarzenegger
okay this is an interesting illusion
which is gonna create a force
um and uh you're uh the the year of one
of your favorite movies
let's go 1991 Terminator 2. Okay and
then last thing an occupation or a job
uh let's do baseball base baseball
player
okay
I have I'm gonna write this I have a
YouTube channel
where I need to shout out
my Patron
whom I call a super sexy reject
his name is Kevin smart
generate a shout out for me
incorporating
these words
which are gold tracks
keep it at
40 words or less
Gotta Love AI all right
all right
big shout out to our super sexy reject
Kevin smart rocking it like Arnold
Schwarzenegger in 1991. you're the Iron
Man of gold treasure keeping it cool
those tiny shorts like a pro baseball
player thanks for your epic support
Kevin you're the real MVP like Chachi BT
oh dang it did it all that's smart like
you Kevin
wow it took longer to get there than it
was to read it yeah thank you Andrew
had to explain adjectives
this is for the sink
foreign